the IRS is out with new data on this
year's tax filings we are four weeks
into tax season and the average refund
so far is two thousand six hundred and
forty dollars now that's down for more
than five hundred dollars from this time
last year the IRS has received fewer
than forty million individual filings so
far down nearly five percent from the
same period and 2018 CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
when you can expect your tax refund Jill
good morning Maury you've already said
you are not anticipating a refund but of
course we know many Americans are how
long can they expect to get one after
they filed if you file electronically it
should be within 21 days if you are
going with the paper filing we're
talking about six weeks or so and again
this is based on the information from
the IRS no delays due to the government
shutdown there were some fears about
that earlier so if there are any delays
what would be the reasons for them I
think the biggest one is that people who
claim the earn interest tax credit or
the additional child tax credit a lot of
those people filed early hoping to get
those credits unfortunately they are not
issued until mid-february the IRS says
tomorrow if you filed those two kinds of
credits you should get your refund
direct deposited and Jill some people
have gotten their tax cut because there
there are people who got tax cuts as a
result of the president tax plan they
got that earlier in their paychecks so
they may not get a refund but their net
tax bill will have gone down right and I
think this is really important because
when we look at that refund amount that
we just cited when we came in we said
hey it's down by $500 now think about
that $500 but if you got a $10 a week
pay increase throughout the year you may
not have noticed it I get it but that
was part of your tax refund and so it's
important not to complete a refund with
a tax cut right because the refund is
essentially you're giving a free loan to
the government and as a financial
adviser you tell people probably not to
do that no not the best idea for people
who do get a refund what do you
recommend they do with the money we want
you to catch your stop it now catch up
on your bills obviously then of course
pay down any outstanding credit card
auto loan debt want to try to beef up
that emergency reserve
fun that's so important and look if
you've got some extra money maybe bump
up that contribution to your retirement
account it's an easy way to do it if you
missed that $10 a week previously in the
previous here use that capture it put it
into your retirement account by the way
putting money into a retirement account
is a great way to reduce your taxes for
next tax season mmm regardless of your
age even if you're your young person put
money in worry to do it just do it all
of that available in your book shell
thank you so much